[Musik]
auf und davon
mit der mobiliar versicherungen und
vorsorge
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in kanada ist josef an meiner ohne seine
frau beatrix im stress plan haben ein
paar sachen zu erledigen
das könnte gerade durchmache in der
letzten folge trieben die als ihr
geschäft mit dem motel weiter voran
zum ende des sommers verließ mutter
beatrice ihre familie und reist dafür
zweieinhalb monate in die schweiz der
küsten imbiss an der nordsee ist endlich
offen und sascha und brigit
konservierten zum ersten mal würste und
winfried team und noemi kamen mit ihrer
großmutter in dorum an ein wiedersehen
nach sechs langen wochen auf der
baustelle in uruguay hat es muss ein
althaus die ehemalige pflegefachfrau
mühe mit den staat bis ihre ferien lot
steht lebt sie mit ihrem mann ruhe die
in einem wohncontainer
es ist schön
[Musik]
ein morgen wie jeder andere und doch
herrscht ein klein wenig ernüchterung
schon zwei monate ist susan in uruguay
und langsam realisiert sie wie weit die
heimat entfernt ist
bisher hatte sie ihre familie und die
freunde immer in der nähe
in ihrem großen haus in schupbach im
emmental konnte sie alle um sich
versammeln
[Musik]
jetzt gibt es nur noch ruhe die und
diese 14 quadratmeter die vielen
weltweiten mit sich bringen zusammen
dachte gar daran alles hinzuschmeißen
von geburtstag
es ist exakt office of clean room hoch
bonner büro aus und das ist auch das ist
ja ich will zwar nicht das aus wie
einfach und so engagiert er für das
interesse ist groß ich gesehen dass ich
doch der beginnende südamerikanische
frühling brachte wieder licht in
susannes gemüt keine größere strom
funktionieren
ja sie denn effektiv zusammen frau aber
das ist eine top funktioniert aber das
super mit dem bau der usada in uruguay
waren sie nicht zum ersten mal den
neuanfang vor fünf jahren befanden sich
rudi und seine frau in einer krise waren
vorübergehend getrennt und haben doch
wieder zusammengefunden
seitdem wissen sie erst recht was sie
aneinander haben
das gibt kraft für das gemeinsame
projekt
[Musik]
zusätzlich zieht dann auch der kirche
zurzeit gegen gc nach der gerade über
die physische geschlossenes familie
suzuki-fahrer welt tätig das ist gerade
bei
noch ist der weg weit bis ihrer prosa
dasteht
es sind kleine dinge die für susanne
einen großen unterschied machen
[Musik]
ende oktober im osten kanadas in der
provinz nova scotia verabschiedet sich
der indian summer
in täter markus bereitet josef schneider
das modell für halloween vor
seit gut vier wochen ist er mit den
kindern allein
[Applaus]
halloween glaubte bereit machen das
wichtigste wie halloween der sonne riese
die wichtige eigentlich aber da muss ich
der in der haut passen das meinungsbild
auch dazu dass man ein kinderspiel
während durch ausgerechnet jetzt wo
mutter beatrice in der schweiz ist hat
sich so ein auftreten arm gebrochen
andré ist nach dem unterricht auf dem
spielplatz gestürzt er konnte auf der
krankenstation in pädagogisch nicht
behandelt werden
für den gips musste er bis in die
provinzhauptstadt halifax und dann
wieder zwei stunden und spittaler stoch
recht lang gewartet sagte und jasper und
ich mir vieles planten formfehlers
amerell vor organisiert oder so moment
vorne plane
die gästebetreuung motel übergab josef
einer mitarbeiterin
sophie und robin brachte er bei freunden
unter
[Musik]
von andres unfall hat beatrice in der
backstube erfahren
mehr als 5000 kilometer entfernt
produziert sie anis kurzen zentnerweise
zusammen mit ihrem mann josef hat sie
entschieden dass sie das geschäft mit
dem süßgebäck trotz auswanderung
weiterführt das ist also die station
mich da nicht hin so schoss kurz team
und da war aber immer alles und bewertet
lockt der können später unter anderem
mit anderen 2 und verlebte das wäre
einfach gesehen auch wenn beatrice es
sich anders wünscht
momentan kann sie ihren sohn nur aus der
ferne trösten
in kanada hatte keine zeit an seinem
gebrochenen arm zu denken
die kinder wollen zur halloween tour und
haben sich mit ihren freunden aus der
schule verabredet
die nächsten stunden ziehen sie
gemeinsam durch die nachbarschaft trick
or treat süßes oder saures heißt es auch
im motel das modell der anna das ist an
diesem abend sehr beliebt trotz
nebensaison
[Musik]
[Applaus]
an der nordsee zieht es timo und noemi
mit ihrer großmutter ans meer
[Applaus]
sie wollen denn im bis 10
seit zehn tagen sind ihre eltern dort
die chefs thema kennt sich in dorum
bereits aus viele jahre lang kam er mit
seinen eltern hierher in die ferien
der 13 jährige ist nicht ganz unschuldig
daran dass seine eltern nun einen imbiss
besitzen
janitos xing im schild
dorthin muss jetzt passieren
jetzt links
dann ist es soweit timo noemi und susann
sehen den küsten bis zum ersten mal in
echt trotzdem einmal mehr spezial- und 6
2 durch brigitte sasse haben keine zeit
sich um die kinder zu kümmern
der andrang ist so groß und riesig
freute
susan muss sich mit dem essen noch etwas
gedulden
zuerst kommt die imbissbude dann die
wurst
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nur 60 kilometer vom neuen daheim der
emmentaler entfernt trifft man auf
schweizer geschichte
[Musik]
rudi und susann gönnen sich eine pause
sie besuchen waiver helvetia zusammen
mit alex ihre auswanderungs beraterin
[Musik]
vor 150 jahren waren schweizer der armut
entkommen und hatten sich in uruguay
niedergelassen
heute ist das ganz anders rotieren susan
können hier einen traum verwirklichen
auf wunsch der auswanderer hat alex
einen 100 züchter ausfindig gemacht
daniel züchtet eine ganz spezielle rasse
denn sie machen oder branche ein hund
der den beiden besonders gut gefällt
und ja also ich wäre die mit dem sinn
machen
die beiden welpen wurden von neun wochen
geboren
wenn sie ausgewachsen sind wegen sie gut
45 kilo
[Applaus]
mein ja naja ihr solltet entscheiden
wenn welchen also ich finde sie
irgendwas da lassen und dann machen wir
dann irgendwann abholen wollte haben sie
ein neues familienmitglied fehlt nur
noch der passende name
besondere unternehmen mit
[Musik]
in turbenthal im kanton zürich bereitet
beatrice den nächsten markttag vor fast
1000 kilogramm teig verarbeitet sie
während der saison
dafür steht sie von früh bis spät in der
backstube komische situation vor
kleinstadt ein drittel der kurze liefert
sie an einen großverteiler den rest
verkauft sie selbst 20 verschiedene
märkte besucht sie in der deutschschweiz
[Musik]
die künstler angst dass wir das relativ
lange bis er nach wunsch wissensstand
über wunsch und das ist ja auch sagt ja
das funktioniert alles
[Musik]
in kanada ist ehemann josef immer wieder
aufs neue gefordert
[Musik]
der ledige soft das könnte durchaus
gespielt würde mache das problem ein
streit unter geschwistern alle kollegen
durften schon auf andrés gips
unterschreiben
nur so viel noch nicht josef muss nicht
nur die eigenen kinder managen sondern
auch deren freunde die sich im hotel wie
zu hause fühlen hand hat und disziplin
das ganze bringt ja wenn rösler ich
schätze mal dass manchmal kommt ja bitte
längst zählt die tage bis seine frau
wieder da ist
[Musik]
an der nordsee muss susan nicht nur
wechselgeld sondern auch brötchen für
den imbiss organisieren
einfach genau für solche jobs wäre
eigentlich der große sohn kevin
eingeplant gewesen doch der hat sich
umentschieden er will nicht mehr nach
dorum kommen möglich dass derlei
zwischenfälle stelle passiert
nein nein ich bin nicht nach ferne
schauen bringen aber ich glaube nicht
dass es das haben
[Musik]
dank dem spontanen einsatz von timo und
zu sein
kommen die brötchen gerade noch
rechtzeitig das münzgeld aber entspricht
nicht ganz präzis vorstellungen auch ein
52 cent münzen hat sie mitgebracht aber
die braucht ihre tochter so gut wie nie
[Musik]
sind sie schon einmal gestanden
denn wird schwierig und denn wer es gar
nicht machbar das eine wirkung
juni juli august 250 und dann bekommt
zusammen sie doch noch ihre currywurst
[Musik]
bis rudi und susann in uruguay mit ihrer
bussarde abheben des noch viel zu tun
[Musik]
die aktionswoche eines schwimmbad
händlers in montevideo wollen sie nutzen
und einen pool aussuchen für sich und
ihre zukünftigen gäste
mehr
einmal mehr unterstützt sie alex dabei
der verkäufer schlägt flavia vor ein
fertig pool mit 30.000 liter
fassungsvermögen
diese woche ist das becken im
sonderangebot die kosten für ihr projekt
hat rudi genau berechnet knapp zwei
jahre können sie ohne einkommen
überleben
der vcs menschen also die frage also
dreht wirklich gut wird unterschreiben
viel gut alles gut das geschäft scheint
für beide aufzugehen
mit nur zwei jahren diese thematik
durchgeführt
[Musik]
in wil im kanton st gallen bereiten sich
die händler für den ort maß markt vor
auch beatrix hat dort einen stand schon
als kind begleitete sie ihre mutter zum
mosley verkauf seit zwölf jahren bietet
sie das süßgebäck auf eigene rechnung an
ihre waren laufen nicht überall gleich
gut je nach ort und witterung ist der
umsatz ganz unterschiedlich kein
markttag ist wieder andere
wo sehr viel auf darum 2300 das ist
nicht so dass es auf das jetzt gerade
das letzte schwere finanzielle hilfe
franken
das geld von den wurzeln können einmal
das in kanada gut gebrauchen
auch wenn sie ihr umsatzziel im hotel
bereits erreicht haben
josef will weiter investieren und den
keller unter dem hauptgebäude ausbauen
nachbar charles hilft ihm dabei und
kümmert sich um die elektrik
geburtstag funktioniert jeder hat mit
leidenschaft sogar eigentlich bereits
alles elektrische widerstand war
eigentlich das main event gemacht
der handwerker vertröstet josef aber
immer wieder aufs neue
truman capotes freund sondern
money talks jeden tag noch weh
dabei wäre jetzt die ideale zeit für den
umbau sei es kühler geworden ist kommen
kaum noch touristen
in frage stellen und teilt sich ja zum
zweifachen energie sparen
anders als der vorbesitzer möchte josef
das motel nicht komplett schließen
dennoch macht er über den winter acht
zimmer dicht
diesmal beauftragt er den klempner in
zukunft möchte josef das selber machen
können
die männer müssen sämtliche
wasserleitungen entleeren damit sie bei
frost nicht platzen und unter dem
gebäude
dass wir das schlimmste was man hier und
da muss nicht gefriert ist überhaupt
hier unter den ersten monaten - 20 so
friert das wasser von draußen das ein
abgestellter das musst du ihn ablehnen
okay ja diese wo hat das wollte wieder
zurück zu reden wenn man das zu machen
also noch drinnen da wohl dass dies
rauswurf verstehe ist okay die nicht aus
muss sie die würde der ich schalte wenn
wenn sich jetzt nur einmal da wird also
zum beispiel jetzt dass ich eigentlich
auch drin noch heute der reserve für das
hockey turnier oder aus damit ich müsste
jetzt noch überlegen ob man sich genau
wie die stelle wieder
[Musik]
gedanken ist
in ein paar wochen beginnt der winter
entweder mit gästen im hotel oder mit
mehr ruhe als denn alma das lieb ist
[Musik]
am kutterhafen in dorum-neufeld ist es
ruhig sehr ruhig ein teil der boden ist
sogar geschlossen und sich damit vom
traum breite hamburg am randweg wie
runter getränke nur vereinzelt von
camping oder so und jetzt vielleicht
lacht uns jetzt dass wir zum schluss
zeigt dem motto zu erlösen und dann
heißt die als nicht nötig oder
regensburg wartet ein schoko und tom
hamburg sein nehmen auch ein hoch bei
jedem wetter bis ende oktober
[Musik]
seit einem monat stehen sascha und
brigit tagein tagaus hinter dem grill
oft mehr als zehn stunden zieht jetzt
sagt jetzt sowohl für tier seebad machen
wir haben bis ende oktober sind kanton
waren sehr viele positive rückmeldungen
und das ist eigentlich das war im
aufstellt
wieder frei zum coach of the work life
balance schauen ob die züge jung dankes
buch damit so was kommt denn schon zu
hause packt tochter noemi für das erste
training im neuen cheerleading verein
der sport ist ihr ein und alles die
letzten jahre ging sie in basel zu den
unicorns
das wetter ist zu schlecht sascha und
brigit haben den imbiss für heute
geschlossen
das gute daran sie können mit zum
training von noemi bei den ice angels
die zahlen überraschen dass sowohl für
die dank stark wo sich europa hat wohl
an sie werde mama im verlag im spital
der basler für den tschechen
außer man hat es ihr auftreten ein
fehler jetzt liegt und ich springe aber
ich weiß nicht ob es mir leid
und ob ich das alles lernen schaffen
dürfte doch wieder mal loslassen
nein wir alles glück der aussies
januar am schwebender von eur 220 kunden
glauben sieht der verband auch sie sehen
nun muss nun zeigen ob sie mit dem
niveau der anderen mädchen mithalten
kann
ich hoffe die spar aber sie sind
ausdruck sind desto vor dem nama und
logistische stroke unit team sportlich
dem team in der gruppe e und buchte sich
sogar jahre lang sein und das buch nie
viel und so bis es wieder ganz
funktioniert das fangen macht noemi noch
probleme reicht es für den auftritt
wochen später in uruguay
der erste bungalow steht vier weitere
fehler noch 75 kubikmeter beton 600
quadratmeter holzplatten sowie 300 kilo
schrauben haben die emmentaler schon
verbaut oft alleine aber immer wieder
auch mit helfern aus der schweiz
selbst die neuen freunde packen mit an
marx ein ausgewanderter zürcher
unterstützt die beiden wo er kann
der jüngste sohn meldet sich mit einer
kollegin aus der heimat nicht als erste
stufe fand schlafzimmer
da geht es einer schafft dann als
zweites mal 18 mit papieren und das
steht auch so gedacht vielleicht ist die
erste beerdigung sie der ja mit nehmen
kontakt kann diese einfach gegangen und
der ge die familie
und der elite ort war und wie sie zu
ergangene mutter und mich sehr lange mit
diesem anderen geld das die gespräche
aber mit sets und das ist gut so
und dann rollt der bagger die ersten
gäste kommen zwar erst in einem jahr hat
doch schon jetzt will verdi den
swimmingpool installieren lassen
neue werke
etwa parlament
der gelernte bau schreiner in der
zuschauerrolle
langsam aber stetig geht es auf der
baustelle voran
und mit jedem weiteren tag fühlt sich
susanne in uruguay ein wenig mehr daheim
[Musik]
in bremerhaven ist das training zu ende
seine gesenkten das was ziemlich reichen
könnte sind auftritt kannst du
zerstreuen
also wenn das morgen zeitig pass wirkung
denn es kommt ansonsten ein bisschen
ruhiger ab und zu noch mal dann würde
die noch mehr schaffen aber dafür dass
das erste mal richtiges training nach
den sommerferien
[Musik]
der einstein dem neuen cheerleading
verein ist neue regelungen kommen sie
nach dem auftritt morgen gleich mit uns
[Musik]
samstagmorgen in kanada kurz vor 7 uhr
wien muss zum ice hockey
andrea kommt mit trotz einbruch damit
beweist dass zur küste und das muss gar
nicht
das ist normalerweise macht immer josef
das frühstück auch wenn nur noch weniger
gäste hier sind aber heute übernimmt das
für einmal klären
beim schnupper training im eishockey
verein möchte josef seine buben nicht
allein lassen
dennoch ist er in gedanken immer wieder
im hotel
beschäftigung in wichtigen ländern
eigentlich euro pro minute
[Applaus]
josef hat mit seinen kindern bald das
zweite drittel ohne beatrix gemeistert
nun hofft er dass das leben keine
weiteren überraschungen bereithält
das time out in der liebe fordert ihn
schon genug
wer fällt auf im herbst stürme und
hochwasser an der nordsee in der
nächsten folge
die baselbieter bringen den imbisswagen
ins winterlager in ober konklave susan
ist seit tagen an isolieren und erobert
sein neues terrain
[Musik]
lang ersehntes wiedersehen in kanada
beatrice kommt endlich heim und die
modelle hat josef für seine frau eine
überraschung
[Musik]
auf und davon
mit der mobiliar versicherungen und
vorsorge